I was born to two amazing professors
who were not religious.
In fact, my father's regular response
to the question about why we didn't go
to church on Sundays was,
"When others go to pray, I go to play."
Tennis, in case you're wondering.
Faith found me and my siblings
when university students came to our house
to invite us to Sunday school.
I was drawn by their sense
of personal conviction
and their life of service,
and opted for baptism
into the Christian faith
as my 10th birthday present.
My faith has shaped my work
as a social entrepreneur,
attempting to address
Africa's most pressing challenges
over the last 17 years,
and my work training youth as leaders
and promoting ethics across Africa.
Twenty-nine years later,
as a Sunday school teacher myself,
my faith was challenged
by a young nine-year-old
who asked a series of questions.
He asked,
"Ms. Ndidi, does God hate Africans?"
To which I quickly retorted,
"Of course not.
God loves all his children equally."
Then he asked, "So why do so many
young African children die?"
I stumbled and mumbled as I responded.
"There are many reasons
why young African children die.
Most of them are man-made,
and we cannot blame God."
So he asked, "Why does he let it happen?
He could stop it."
And I said ...
"Yes he could, yes he could,
but he sent us here as change agents,
light of the world, salt of the earth,
and we are failing."
Africa has had a mixed affair
with organized religion,
with both positive
and negative consequences.
The Christian missionaries
educated most of our political elite,
like Senghor and Nkrumah,
built many of our first
hospitals and schools.
Similarly, Islam has introduced
commerce and mathematics
across the continent.
Today, we have over a billion Africans
who profess a strong faith.
What is the net effect
of this on our continent?
A recent "Economist" article
said that the face of the future
of the world's most popular
religion is African.
Now, both Islam and Christianity
underscore the importance of social impact
as critical tenets of our faith.
Muhammad is noted for stating
that he is not a believer
who goes to bed on a full stomach
when his neighbor to his side is hungry.
And all through the New Testament,
Jesus Christ talks about loving
your neighbors as yourselves,
giving to the poor, caring for the sick,
and James, too, says
that "faith without works is dead."
So I strongly believe that faith-based
organizations have a critical role to play
in driving social impact in Africa.
But for this to occur,
we need three critical changes.
The first is that we need
to change our mindsets.
Both as people of faith
and of those who are not religious,
their perceptions of those of us
who are people of faith.
Now, for people of faith
and those of us who are religious,
we often say, "If God wills, I'll do this;
inshallah, I'll do that --
by God's grace, I'll do this."
Now there are many things,
I believe, that we can control --
some we cannot.
I believe that God is all-powerful,
but he's not a micromanager.
(Laughter)
He has sent us here as his change agents,
and we must stop making excuses
and using him.
That means that if you're a teacher,
go to school and give
your students the best.
If you're a public-sector official,
release the funds meant for that school
or public health-care center
instead of stealing it
for your personal purposes.
By claiming that we have no power
over our past, present and future,
we give too much authority to the wicked
who steal funds
and beg God for forgiveness.
Now for those of you
who are not religious,
you also have to change
your mindsets about us.
There are many of us who are hardworking,
ethical and intellectual.
It might surprise you.
(Laughter)
Now the second step
is that we have to utilize
our resources and assets
for social impact.
In England,
1,900 churches have been
shut down since 1969,
due to shrinking congregations,
while in Africa, every single day,
a church or mosque is being built.
In some communities,
you might not find a public health center,
a post office or even a school,
but you'll find a church or mosque.
Some of these churches
and mosques are world-class,
with excellent audio-visual systems,
wonderful meeting spaces,
and they organize events
that rival international concerts.
The sad reality is that many of them
are empty during the week.
I live in the Lekki area of Lagos,
and in my community, there are at least
50 really nice churches,
but there's no adult literacy center,
no homeless shelter
and very few public schools and hospitals.
Many of these spaces
could be utilized for social change.
Imagine if every single church
in Lekki opened its doors
to the homeless at night,
gave them a sleeping bag, a warm meal
and a voucher in the morning
to learn a vocational course,
offered by the unemployed youth
who attend that church.
That would demonstrate what we preach
and what we speak about
as people of faith,
and what led me to Christianity
in the first place.
Similarly, we have to utilize
our resources for social change.
The 2016 "why give" survey
conducted in Kenya
reveals that close to 60 percent of adults
give to faith-based organizations --
even more than they give
their extended families.
This is not unique to Kenya.
It's quite prevalent across Africa.
Many of our faith-based organizations
have tremendous amounts of wealth
that can be utilized for social change.
We have to check the sources
of uses of these funds
and curb the excesses
by our faith-based organizations.
Now, this will require courage
on the part of members,
who will have to put their
imams and priests on straight salaries,
require audited financial statements
that will be published
and even reject contributions
from unethical sources.
But it's possible.
We're already seeing positive examples
in South Africa and Kenya,
and the organizations,
such as the Africa Council
for Accreditation and Accountability
that's checking faith-based organizations
and ensuring that they comply
with biblical standards of stewardship.
Now, the third step
is that we have to partner
with all stakeholders,
and this is especially relevant
for the non-religious in the audience.
Recognizing the power and potential
of faith-based organizations,
leveraging their assets, their scale,
the public trust
and credibility they have,
their lower operating costs,
their access to the grassroots
and their presence abroad.
Politicians recognize this,
and campaign seasons are always filled
with stops and picture opportunities
with leading faith leaders.
Sadly, once elected,
many of these faith-based
organizations are ignored.
And in fact, a World Bank survey revealed
that 30 to 70 percent of assets
owned by medical organizations in Africa
are actually owned
by faith-based organizations,
but that there's very little collaboration
between the faith community
and public health-care systems.
One positive example is from Ghana,
where the Ghana Catholic Health Service
partnered with a range of stakeholders
and was able to realize
a 31 percent reduction in mortality.
I believe there's so much potential
that can be realized
when we walk across the divide of faith
and, hand in hand, try to solve
many of our problems.
Similarly, faith-based organizations
can support the transfer
of critical skills and knowledge.
Many of you in the NGO community
or in the private sectors
realize how difficult it is
to even attract 150 to 200 people
to your conferences,
sometimes even offering stipends,
reimbursements of transportation costs.
Meanwhile, faith-based organizations
draw thousands and millions
every Sunday or Friday ...
with the promise of a good sermon.
The truth is we cannot address
issues around family planning
without faith-based
organizations in Africa.
Issues such as democratic rights
and voter registration,
ensuring that every member
of a congregation
has a voter registration card,
understands their democratic rights
and can exercise that.
I really think it's critical
that we consider partnering
with faith-based organizations
to deliver social impact.
It's also important to note
that African faith-based organizations
have a strong presence globally.
There are over 2,000 African nuns
and priests in leadership positions
in Europe,
with more influence
than some of our diplomatic envoys,
operating at a fraction of the cost.
They can serve as influencers
and supporters.
Similarly, some African churches
have a presence
in countries across the globe,
and the Redeemed Christian Church of God
has a presence in 196 countries,
serving as a bridge to the diaspora
and providing support.
If our public-sector organizations
could partner with these institutions,
we could unlock the potential
of our diaspora populations.
I know some of you
are still struggling with this topic,
but I challenge you to think about it.
A wise man once said, "Faith is a risk,
but it's a risk that I cannot
afford not to take."
I would suggest that partnerships
with faith-based organizations are a risk,
but one that all stakeholders that are
committed to social impact in Africa
cannot afford not to take.
I often reflect on my conversation
with that young boy,
and I believe I should have ended it
a little differently.
First, I should have commended him
for asking tough questions.
Africa needs more young people
who challenge the status quo,
even in the faith communities.
Secondly, I should have given him
a little more hope.
Not hope in the afterlife,
but hope in Africa today,
because the faithful are powerful.
Not just because of their beliefs
but because of their assets,
their resources, their army of volunteers,
and because working together,
across the divide,
we can live as positive examples
for what our children --
my children, your children --
deserve to see.
An Africa that demonstrates
that God loves Africans
and that we are just as capable
as any other world region
in solving our problems
in peace ...
and love.
I love this quote that says,
"Hope is the ability to hear
the melody of the future.
Faith is the willingness and the courage
to dance to it today."
I hope that we, as people of faith,
can truly live up to
the promise of social impact
that we have been called to do
as change agents in society.
And I believe that working with you,
all stakeholders,
we can truly solve
Africa's most pressing challenges.
I have that hope ...
and I have the faith,
and I've started to dance.
Won't you join me?
Thank you.
(Applause)